disgraced crypto King Sam bankman freed
making his first U.S court appearance in
New York after being extradited he is
facing a slew of fraud charges that
could land him behind bars for the rest
of his life the FTX founder out of jail
after posting a massive 250 million
dollar bond which one prosecutor calls
the largest ever begman freed will now
have to live under house arrest at his
parents home in California while he
awaits trial
this comes as Sam's former friends
including his ex-girlfriend flip on him
two former top Executives of begman
Freed's crypto trading empire have pled
guilty to Federal Criminal fraud charges
and are cooperating with the feds
um judge I want to go to you first where
are we bird's eye view where are we
right now in this case well the fact
that we didn't find out about Ellison
and uh Wang the girlfriend who ran
Alameda and Wang until last night uh to
me tells why it took so long for the
arrest of Sam bankman freed everyone's
saying why aren't they arresting why
aren't they arresting him they wanted
the feds clearly wanted to get uh these
two to plead guilty to very similar
charges they have to meet the conditions
of the plea deal the conditions of the
plea deal are that they testify and
cooperate with the feds incriminating
Sam bankman freed that was done and tied
up last night and as soon as they landed
in New York it it was a done deal what
that means is that the chances of this
going to trial are slim to none you've
got these two who were working with him
pretty much at his level Alameda the
girlfriend who was feeding the getting
the money fed to her
um was someone who it was involved in
the day-to-day activities with him as
his wife a couple of thoughts 250
million dollars bond is 25 million
dollars Bond basically you put up the
parents are putting up their house
um and I don't understand that because
the parents have yet to be investigated
as well there are issues as it relates
to the parents but that's for another
day now the cooperation that they give
to the feds will determine their own
sentence so the difference between the
feds and most state prosecutions is as a
as a state judge I would give a sentence
of X they had to serve that X the feds
can dance around with it and say you
know what uh we're going to go in and
maybe they won't be sentenced until
after bankman freedas but they can go
one and say they cooperated and we were
going to give them a lesser sentence
than we thought we were going to give
them now Sam bankman free he can't get
away with this by saying I didn't know
enough he actually had no guidance no
regulation no oversight he used the
money for himself the money that went to
Alameda and his girlfriend was then used
for lavish gifts and homes for himself
and his family his family which I
believe includes his parents which is
you know pretty crazy here but the the
in the end this guy's worse and Madoff
and the reason he's worse than Madoff is
that made up of the money's much higher
but Madoff use an individual's money to
pay another individual this Sam bankman
freed used the money for a lavish
lifestyle for himself his family in real
estate he's a dirtbag big time
dirt bag you think he's a dirt bag as
well I assume and do you think that this
also isn't a Ponzi scheme because that's
essentially what you're saying what
Madoff did was a Ponzi scheme and this
is worse it's a little different a
little just a little I think a lot
different yeah it's it's theft okay we
can focus on Sam bankman Freedom by the
way just noticing as we're speaking here
that Court sketch is the most flattering
course set I have ever seen he is not as
good looking as the artist no Praise Him
[Music]
listen here's the story that matters to
me Jessica it is less about Sam bankman
freed it is more about where Sam bankman
freed spent his money and I'm not
talking about the homes or the lavish
Lifestyles it's the people that
benefited from his large s it is the
media organizations that he funded we're
up to I think almost a half a dozen
media organizations who were living in
some part off of the funds from FTX it's
Democrat politicians who are getting big
campaign donations from Sam bankman
freedom to me this is the story okay and
the quick story is this we have a
society right now where people are
unwitting participants in shaping their
own lives I think we were given
incomplete and false information on so
many aspects of covid what you have here
is a bank of customers for FDX who were
unwilling participants in Sam Bateman
Freed's vision of the world I will shape
it for you through media I will shape it
through you for politics and these
people did not choose to participate in
his manipulation of our world
very interesting um
I'm sure you have
some Will's assessment and I'd love to
know also do you think that this will
lead to more attempts at least of
government regulation well first of all
that 250 million dollar bond is just so
eye-popping they say it's the largest
Bond they've ever put out according to
the U.S attorney I'm fascinated to see
how the defense argues that this is an
unregulated industry so therefore you
can't hold my client accountable for
rules that aren't in place they're going
to say it's for they're trying to get
them on fraud but I think that they
would probably argue that look there's
no regulation in place for you to say
where the guard rails are so how can you
hold someone accountable when the
government has failed to implement these
regulations we've known for a long time
that people in Capitol Hill have been
paid by FTX they wanted to get in in
their good graces by trying to pay them
off so they wouldn't regulate crypto the
problem is now you're hearing a lot from
politicians of going way too far on the
other side of the regulation they're
acting like this is a representation or
an indictment of the crypto industry as
a whole when people in the industry are
saying no no this guy was was
fraudulently using people's money he was
stealing people's money don't paint us
with the same broad brush just because
you guys want to regulate the industry
in a way that allows you to have more
government control and so I think it's
going to be really fascinating to watch
how this moves forward in this trial or
maybe not trial in the case but also
with legislation and how they try to
figure out how they can crack down and
whether it just applies as fraud or
whether it's going to be some other new
regulator industry real fast one of the
things that the prosecutors did was they
got the co-defendants to plead to both
Securities and a
Securities crimes so that there wouldn't
be this issue about regulation and since
they admitted to it they're going to
establish a case that we got them on
Securities so I think their the defense
is going to have a hard time with that
one yeah but I think they may make the
case just because the regulations
might not work really quick I'll give
you a quick street level assessment the
two things that popped out of me the
most today 250 million dollar bail the
fact that this guy had a girlfriend okay
I mean that everybody was a little blown
away when they heard that let me just
oversimplify this case I don't know
anything about crypto I don't know
anything about regulation but there's a
very simple investment tip for everybody
watching at home never give your life
savings to a guy who shows up to the
meeting in shorts and a stained t-shirt
it's a tell it's like if you're on the
street and you begin in the transaction
with you're not a cop are you they're
kind of telling you this guy was a
dirtbag he did a symposium a crypto
Symposium with Bill Clinton in the
Bahamas where he showed up in shorts
like you know what's bad when Bill
Clinton tells you to put pants on but
that's who this guy was he was a dirt it
back and people weren't asleep at the
wheel they were awake at the ATM there
was so much money flying around that
every one of these Dirtbag celebrities
Tom Brady is a dirt bag for this he's
hey I'm with my pal SPF excuse me
Shaquille O'Neal I'm all in on this
stuff okay Larry David all in on this
stuff this guy had credibility not
because of his appearance which I'm
mocking but because he was aligned with
the right people it was their
credibility he traded off to dupe all of
these poor people out of their life
savings dirtbag
Dirtbag is the word of the block all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else